here the nominees for achievement and  makeup and hairstyling Hitchcock Howard  Berger Peter Montaigne Martinson The  Hobbit  an unexpected journey Peter's swords  King Rick Finlay turd and Tammy Lane  they miss it up Lisa Westcott and Julie  dart Nellie  [Applause]  and the Oscar goes to  lemons arrest  [Music]  this is the first Academy Award for Lisa  Westcott and Julie Darnell  [Music]  whoa thank you so much the Academy I  don't know it's quite overwhelming and I  must fare Putra Butte to the team who  worked so incredibly hard and was so  talented and I feel that I only own a  little bit of this and the rest goes to  them thank you very much thank you very  much it's an incredible honor thank you  so much and I just want to give love to  my family my mom my dad Tom Holly and  Dave thank you  [Applause]